how's it going everybody it's Warren and
to say that the 2005 and 2015 fantastic
for movies where letdowns is probably an
understatement many fans were very
disappointed with how the two movies
came out and were worried that we may
not ever get a good Fantastic Four movie
again
that is until Disney officially acquired
the rights of the characters from Fox
and can now use them in their own movies
and in the MCU and then there was hope
in the fandom again and then there was
even more hope when about a week ago
there was a report that said Marvel is
actually trying to develop a Fantastic
Four movie and get them into the MCU as
soon as possible this report came from
MCU cosmic comm who claims that two
separate sources both told him that
Marvel is developing a Fantastic Four
movie obviously everybody started to
freak out because this is very exciting
news and then the fan casting began for
a very long time now fans have wanted
John Krasinski to play mr. fantastic and
Emily Blunt to play The Invisible Woman
and that has stayed the same with fans
also wanting Zac Efron to play the Human
Torch and Dwayne the rock Johnson to
play the thing but now there's a rumor
going around that says Marvel is
actually eyeing Liam Hemsworth to play
the role of the Human Torch in the new
Fantastic Four movie Liam Hemsworth is
the younger brother of Chris Hemsworth
who plays Thor in the MCU so it
certainly would be pretty easy for
Marvel to set up a meeting with Liam
Hemsworth liam starred and the Hunger
Games franchise so he knows what it's
like to appear in major movies and there
have been rumors going around that when
Marvel eventually does get around to
doing a Fantastic Four movie they're
going to want to cast younger so Marvel
eyeing Liam Hemsworth to take on the
role of Johnny Storm slash the Human
Torch lines up with that rumor because
he is a younger actor unfortunately
right now nothing is confirmed it's not
even confirmed that we're going to be
getting a Fantastic Four movie yet
eventually of course we will be getting
another Fantastic Four movie but
according to the report from MCU cosmic
we should be getting a Fantastic Four
movie in 2022 and if this report ends up
true then Marvel is going to want to
start looking at casting pretty soon not
to mention ant-man and ant-man and the
wasp director Peyton Reed already has a
script for the Fantastic Four Peyton
Reed actually pitched his idea for his
Fantastic Four movie to Fox executives
over ten years ago but unfortunately
they weren't interested at the time but
the Fantastic Four have always been a
passion project for read and if Marvel
is trying to get the Fantastic Four it
by 2022 and they cast Peyton Reed as the
director and they already have somewhat
of a script that means they're going to
be casting actors very soon and
according to recent rumors Liam
Hemsworth is one of the actors that
Marvel is looking at to possibly cast
for the Human Torch again nothing is
confirmed it's just a rumor for now but
let me know what you would think about
Liam Hemsworth playing the Human Torch
it would be cool if Liam Hemsworth ends
up playing the Human Torch and Chris
Hemsworth continues to play for it would
be cool to see them both on screen the
Fantastic Four interacting with Thor but
again let me know your thoughts on this
do you like the idea of Liam Hemsworth
being cast as the Human Torch slash
Johnny Storm let me know your thoughts
in the comments down below and a
reminder about my giveaway when I hit
450,000 subscribers I will be picking
not one but three winners and each will
get to choose one item from the Marvel
Legends series collection to enter for
your chance to win all you have to do is
be subscribed to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain and I'll be starting giveaways
on Instagram and Twitter pretty soon if
you want to follow me on social media as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very Nass and
all it took
you said it cost you everything while
crying like a baby now your